this is Startalk this is from Nancy
Lilly on Facebook who wants to know do
we know where they're from I love know
one where they're from um no let me see
here some of them say okay a lot of them
say not okay you're right in I always
like no one we yeah just remember that
because that way Chuck and make fun of
your hometown absolutely that's what
comedians do we do that's why comedians
people don't know this but that's why
comedians say hey so where you from you
know that and the fact that I am out of
material material or my material is not
working so hey where you from okay all
right so Nancy Lillian comes to us from
Facebook and she wants to know about
garbage disposal in space hmm because we
clearly have a problem with garbage
disposal here on earth so what how would
trash or garbage be disposed of and if
not what would it do all right so here's
the problem on Mars if Mars is sterile
meaning it's got no life anywhere not
even microbes if that's the case and we
go live on Mars normally what do you do
on earth with your garbage you throw it
yeah we don't we don't burn it anymore
what do we do we put in a laughs yeah we
bury it all right so you bury them you
bury it and eventually it decomposes
okay right all right no what's doing the
decomposing
organisms organisms and so to be
biodegradable means there's some
biological action on your garbage that's
turning it back into the soils from
which it came okay so if you are on Mars
and you bury the garbage it will stay
that way forever
nothing decomposes nothing will
decompose or break down because well not
from biological I mean it there are
certain molecules that won't last
forever
okay but on the timescale that just
because of the the the quantum physics
of molecular vibrations I mean it's a
whole it's their mother right but that's
a whole other that's a whole other thing
we right so so the actual molecular
vibrations may cause the dissolution of
some molecules
correct and it's why and the most stable
form of an atom or molecules when it's
in the form of a crystal that's stable
and then it's not going to
that's why diamonds are forever Chuck
picked up on that so yeah so unless
every what's all of your garbage is in
crystalline form right it's the larger
molecules could ultimately decay but
what you're really banking on is by it
biodegradable which would happen on a
relatively short time scale you know
years or decades
well not thousands of years so you need
another way to dispose of your garbage
absolutely so this basically you would
just turn my so us living there you
eventually turn Mars into a dump and
look into a complete dump that's correct
Wow exactly right and and and what does
it mean for there to be fertilizer in
the ground it means you know they're
microbes interacting you'd have to
create a whole biota right there and
you'd have to terraform Mars in advance
before you before you could absolutely
do it yeah yeah or you could just dump
your stuff on Pluto it's not even a
planet anymore right just take our trash
for Mars ish shoot at the Pluto dump it
on boots jump on Pluto now here's now
you might ask
I know if they did but you could ask why
not just send all the garbage to the Sun
okay the ideal disposal now I can't
believe you just said that why because
when I was a kid and I was very
disturbed by the commercials that I saw
where there was an Indian who said one
single tear for all the trash that was
polluting our earth
I remember that commercial yes and I
would get snowed in the United States
there's no Indians except for in India
but they're different Indians and back
then not that we're being insensitive
back then the concept of Native American
didn't quite kick in yet no not at all
there was an Indian guy with a headdress
right and he saw humans Americans green
goes green goes right I think those
throwing garbage out their window and
then he turned he would turn the camera
and it was a tear just one single tear
streaming down his his face remember
that his non Indian actor face is
basically
so what yeah he wasn't an Indian what
God wasn't out I was Italian no tell me
that I'm not lying I saw a whole like
little mini documentary on how he was
not an Indian even in there or Native
American not at all he was an Italian
guy that actually took on the entire
persona but anyway I used to see that
commercial and I would the the the Clint
Eastwood movies were all Italians right
Getty Western super Kenny West's playing
playing games playing Mexicans so
Italians they got a thing going well
yeah you know what it is because they're
white enough to be white but yet somehow
Olive enough to play somebody else okay
because from northern to southern Italy
exact a whole spec that dispatch from
the Mediterranean ones to the northern
one exactly so you know they Hollywood
was just like hmm we can't actually use
a Native American got me an Italian guy
I would fantasize as a kid from seeing
this commercial about putting all the
trash in the world in a rocket and
shooting it into the Sun and it would
burn up before it ever even reached the
Sun right that's what would happen
that's correct
you loser you lose your rocket - yeah so
so yeah if it's close enough to burn the
trash you're burning the rocket all
right so so this this great brilliant
geeky idea you had as a kid
the problem is it costs a lot of energy
money and energy and rocket fuel just to
do that okay and it's not quite no no
right it's not cost effect of all it
takes so much fuel just to get the
rocket off the ground to get the hell
off of Earth right right so let alone
all the garbage that would have to be in
the rocket right now it's $10,000 a
pound and if we put anything just into
orbit forget what about even leaving
Earth so it is your garbage worth ten
thousand okay well I think not yes and
that is why you ended up being an
astrophysicist and I ended up being
not comic all right well that was great
fascinating stuff the whole know we
would get all that out I didn't mean
this is Startalk